[Music]
today we're going to talk about how you
can build professional web applications
really quickly with corvid using google
cloud services
my name is 'more I'm a developer at week
and I've been working on Quora within
the past three years
so hey everyone and my name is Gators
and for the last two years I'm working
on garbage database systems so let's
talk today about what you need to build
a modern web application well first we
know that we want it to be super fast
because no one likes waiting second we
want to be able to store huge amounts of
data and analytics capabilities and
third we want to have professional UI in
order to get our users engaged with our
service so I'm bringing to you corvid by
Wix whoo so what is Corrine
well it's many things first it's a
visual platform to design your web
applications this is what Wix is for
very famous for its our
what-you-see-is-what-you-get editor for
building web pages so it's know HTML and
know CSS in building the front end and
it's also a truly service platform which
means you can build your back-end
services and call it from front end and
as if it was a simple method and there
is no setup there's no setting up
virtual machines security databases
everything is there for you when to
start your project and furthermore you
can deploy your application with the
single click of a button and in a few
seconds is deploy in two weeks service
servers all around the world so now
we're going to show you a short demo
that we created that is an actual
applications blog application on San
Francisco food see what you can see over
here when Gil juice will scroll down you
can see post on restaurants from San
Francisco each post contained the name
of the of the restaurant a description
and an image now when we'll go up we'll
see that we have tags and we can filter
our posts by the tags now the fun part
about our about our application is that
the tags are being automatically created
when we add the post so yesterday
Guidry's and I went to this really cool
restaurant together with our core VIP
team over here that called cow Marlo and
giedrius will write a short description
of our restaurant and we'll add a photo
that we took yesterday now when we click
on upload post what happening is first
we upload the image to week's media
servers then we save the post in our own
integrated database collection after
that we're doing two things we're
calling Google NLP on the text that we
wrote to receive entities on the text
after that we're calling Google vision
API on the image to get labels on our
image when we finish with that we
combine the two results and create tags
from that then we'll save it in our own
integrated database again let's go to
our new post and see how it looks like
this is the new restaurant and if you'll
go down we'll see that we have some new
tags automatically created for us and we
also have the friendship tag because we
are friends now we'll go to the editor
and we'll see how it actually done so
here you can see our add new place form
yes you know its regular form it has few
input components for restaurant name
short description image and the nice red
button top before uploading the post all
of these components
are connected to the posted data set you
can see over there what that allows us
to do is allows us to submit the data
from the form directly to our database
without writing a single line of code
now since we want to do more processing
when I call Google so we're adding some
code that's going to run after the form
is safe so here you can see we're taking
that same data set I just talked about
and we're adding an on/off to safe
callback now when this once the data is
saved to the database the callback is
going to be invoked and going going to
do a few things so now one of the
interesting things I want to show you is
how we call the backend code you can see
we're calling yet extending this method
that granted get extended this function
is actually important from the backend
language GSW now you may think wait this
is front-end code why we are importing
back-end code so once you import
back-end code from the front-end code in
Corbett what it does it's important that
instead of code calling the JavaScript
directly will go and call the backend
service over HTTP so anything that's in
the backend folder and this has
extension dot jsw which stands like
javascript read method any function
exported from there will become callable
as a web service now because we're using
node.js in the backend we want to be
able to import NPM packages so as you
can see here we're importing google
language api and also lo - now when
Guidry's and i wrote this application we
had some bugs and we wanted to debug our
application so we actually added some
login here but as you know it's a
back-end file so we cannot see that the
logging in our console so what we
actually used is a new feature we have
that enables us to connect to Google
stackdriver and monitory application so
we'll go to Google stackdriver
and we load the new logs and we actually
can see here the entities that we
received from Google now we'll go back
and remember we talked about integrated
databases and collections so this is our
post collection that we use each post
record contains the title the
description the image and the tags that
we have on it now if we go to the tax
collection we'll see all the tags and we
also see the post that connected to the
tags we use a multi reference field here
yeah we have joins so so what did we do
again we use several escort platform the
visual builder integrate a global
available cards database together we're
globally available weeks media platform
and combine that with Google machine
learning services such as NLP and cloud
vision API and use Google's monitoring
tools to build this nice application and
how long did we take we worked on that
for less than three hours with the
design and everything it's very easy
because we don't need to bootstrap
anything and it's server less so we can
actually we don't need to worry about
security hosting nothing you just go in
two weeks creating your website enable
corvid and start coding corvids now are
under a technical preview so you can
start using it all you need to do is
I'll take my clicker to go to Wix
website
www-wait comm slash corvid and start
using our great product so thank you all
for coming here and letting us share a
tiny fraction of our platforms
capabilities if you want to know more
we'd like you to join our booth right on
that corner where we gonna show demos
and we'll let you play with the product
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]